[Music]
it's been a decade of signs and wonders
ten years it's pretty extraordinary it
is just the most remarkable achievement
it's a very conscious act to go and make
a motion picture let alone think about
launching and sustaining a cinematic
universe I mean nobody had even heard of
that five or six years ago
I'm Peter violently dr. strange oh you
should have made up names pretty awesome
to see this collective isn't it I mean
just a bit part of it it's crazy fit any
more people on that poster and everyone
deserves to be there you know everyone
has fought for their place in the MCU
it's such an amazingly humble group of
people and everyone's easy to work with
there are team players surprise this
will be such fun I love all these actors
they've made it so fun it's it's like a
big family really we're all having fun
and were really allowed to be the best
versions of whatever these giant movies
are
you're given a set of circumstances and
a script and you go try to put your
secret sauce on that and make it fun and
entertaining and I think what's
extraordinary is how that baton has been
passed in such a magnanimous way from
all these franchises I'm Steve Rogers
now bring them all together it's just so
epic are you yawning to have created
these different worlds and made them so
sort of full and rich and then bring
them all together for these last two
movies it's so great it's really been
ten years in the making is a very very
unique film I'm glad it's worked out
this way because we have been working
our asses off for a while to have come
this far 19 movies 10 years and still be
going and still have people wanting it
and still be doing something that's new
and profound and culturally significant
that's a dream come true
everybody it's Charlie so Marvel and the
original Avengers are celebrating their
10th anniversary saying you know look at
what we've done with these characters
look at the financial success that we've
turned this studio into they're the
bedrock of what happens in the next 10
years with all these different movies
all the sacrifice all the character
turns so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video most people are freaking out
because they do think that people will
die during Avengers 4 and never come
back
but trust me these are billion-dollar
characters these are franchises toys
will not sell if these characters go
away for forever which is where you get
into multiverse time travel all kinds of
narrative devices that allow them to
kill people to catalyze the team that's
typically what happens in a big
team-based movie like this one of the
people that you love dies that brings
the rest of them together they're not
saying goodbye for forever and I'm not
talking about soul gem black panther
spider-man twist where like they come
right back like you kill all these
people but they literally the next year
show right up Avengers 4 is meant to be
this book end so anybody that dies at
the end of that movie is not coming back
in the future any time soon which like
why I mentioned multiverse and time
travel because we have a couple
franchises that are going to be set
during the past and we have a young
Avengers movie that's coming up in the
future which is a perfect opportunity to
introduce Kang the conquer
imagined Young Avengers jumping all over
the timeline that's a perfect place to
cameo younger versions of pre-existing
characters like a really young version
of Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne or a
younger version of Nick Fury younger
than 90s
Captain Marvel Nick Fury he's gonna be
in his 40s during the events of that
movie so you have to imagine that he's
probably seen even crazier stuff that he
isn't telling people about because he is
the keeper of all Marvel secrets it all
comes back to that Winter Soldier quote
nobody spills the secrets because nobody
knows them all you
the way Kevin Feige teased the plot of
Avengers 4 is that he said it's all
about the original phase one characters
remember because they're the ones that
survived the finger-snap coming together
and learning what it means to be true
hero's true Avengers usually narrative
turns like that require a blood
sacrifice to solidify those bonds it
catalyzed the team so that you believe
in the future that nothing will ever be
strong enough to break them the way that
Thanos broke them during infinity war
because in a very broad sense the whole
idea of why they lost is that they were
split up they weren't a true team like
Captain America and Iron Man weren't on
the same page and even though they were
at their a game they were at their most
powerful iron man had his most extreme
technology it still wasn't enough to
take down Thanos even on the DVD
commentary the Russos were talking about
how Thor almost got Thanos but he made a
mistake because he was acting solo the
whole idea of Avengers 4 is that they
all go in on the same page when they
finally try to take him down for good in
the cool thing is that yeah this is a
bookend so obviously they have to deal
with Thanos completely so that going
forward he's not a big problem but like
we talked about characters coming back
during movie set during the past like
even if Captain America is one of the
people that dies you can bring him back
in a movie that's set during the past
Josh Brolin has already said that he
wants to come back for the Eternals
franchise which might also be set during
the past the Eternals is a really weird
franchise we don't know exactly where
it's going to be set during the timeline
but it's an opportunity to do ancient
history in the MCU think of it like
Knights of the Old Republic in terms of
the Star Wars timeline set during the
distant past but you have all these
crazy heroes Kevin Feige pitched it is
sort of an ancient alien situation all
this crazy mythology and present-day
that's based on the stuff that they did
Thanos wasn't really born till later in
their timeline and he didn't spend a lot
of time on earth until present day when
he was actually trying to go after
either the Cosmic Cube in the comics
were during the events of the Infinity
saga which is what we're seeing play out
right now Kevin Feige did say that we
would see different versions of
pre-existing characters I think that's
him sort of bracing introducing the
concept of passing Mantle's to other
characters but also the idea of the
multiverse I know there are lots of
questions and theories about the actual
plot of Avengers 4 but just from a
narrative device in
things up for the next ten years Kevin
Feige needs to keep certain characters
around because there's such big
franchises like if there's no more Iron
Man or Captain America for instance
those toys will slowly stop selling as
much and that means billions of dollars
the Disney would be out they don't want
that so you just have to think about the
different ways that you keep characters
around so that you keep toys in stores
which is really funny way to think about
character development but that's sort of
the box that they operate in it's the
same thing with the Millennium Falcon in
the Star Wars franchise it is far and
away one of the most popular toys in the
history of Star Wars Lucasfilm found out
a long time ago that if they stopped
putting the Falcon in movies then it
would stop selling as much meaning that
they would be out billions of dollars
it's the same deal with all the Avengers
in their toys like spider-man for
instance probably one of the most
valuable brands amongst comic book
characters in the world that's why it's
so important that Sony and Marvel keep
their sharing arrangement intact should
because the character is so important to
what's happening in the MCU right now
but also Sony is never gonna let that
character go if they can't help it
so just cross your fingers that
everything goes well between Marvel and
Sony in the next year they resize that
sharing arrangement so they don't have
to take Tom Holland away because he in
black panther are two of the most
important characters going into phase
four in important franchises just in
general but what'll happen is is there
was a whole bunch of other stuff that
dropped this week so I'll try to get
through the videos as fast as possible
leave your video requests in the
comments below - I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
click here to learn more about what's
going on with phase 4 Deadpool and the
x-men franchises and click here to
rewatch those infinity war deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]